was that the right move by the voluntary
policy committee to raise rates by 0.5
percent well it was certainly right to
raise interest rates
um perhaps they could have gone further
because it's quite clear that the
interest rate we now have 2.25 is not
going to be sufficient to get on top of
inflation which is nearly 10 percent uh
five times the bank of England's Target
so we're probably going to need further
interest rate Rises over the course of
this year and into the first part of
next year should they have done more
this time there have been an expectation
they'd go for a 0.75 rise well if I'd
been on the NPC I would been voting with
the three members who wanted a 0.75 rise
and um I think that was uh fully
Justified and we've seen in the United
States
them raising interest rates by 0.75 on
three occasions
and in Sweden for example recently they
raised interest rates by one percent
so other central banks are being a bit
more robust and a bit more
um significant in terms of their
interest rate policies well yes and
do you think the impact of the mini
budget will be as we were talking to the
leveling up secretary he was talking
about a raft of tax cuts or certainly
canceling tax Rises as part of this
fiscal event what impact will tax cuts
have on inflation
well I think the danger that we face at
the moment if you've got the bank of
England pushing up interest rates trying
to keep a lid on inflation and try and
contain demand in the economy and then
the government with the other lever of
Economic Policy fiscal policy
putting a big energy price support
package which is going to be funded by
borrowing and then we'll see later today
um quite a few tax cuts are in the
offing and that's going to add to
demanding the economy so it's a bit of a
push push me pull you type of situation
with economic policy with monetary
policy trying to dampen down inflation
but fiscal policy tax and government
spending policy putting more money back
into the economy so the two are working
in opposite directions the government
and the bank of England well it that's
that's the danger
um and it depends on how people respond
uh to the various measures that uh
quasi-quarting is going to announce
today I think the biggest
uh measure is going to be the energy
support package which people are talking
about being 100 to 150 billion but
there's also discussion
um or newspaper talk about uh up to 50
billion pounds of tax cuts on top of
that so that's a that's a very big
fiscal stimulus well yes and it's a lot
of money being spent but one of the
points of the energy support package is
not just to help people be able to
afford their bills of course but won't
it have an effect of dampling down
inflation by limiting prices
yes that's uh that's the sort of
um the positive side of the uh borrowing
that's going we're going to see a large
announcement of of extra borrowing uh
but the positive side is that some of
that is going towards uh helping to ease
the cost of living pressures and that
should help
um head off some of the wage pressures
which could fuel future inflation and
that's one of the dangers that we face
at the moment in the UK economy the bank
of England said yesterday that it's
possible we're already in recession do
you think they're right
well I think uh it's not a recession as
we've known it before I mean what
they're talking about is two
0.1 Falls in GDP in consecutive quarters
now some people would technically call
that a recession but it's it's really a
flat economy because 0.1 is very close
to zero
um previous recessions we've seen GDP
Falling by say one percent in a quarter
or even more so
um I think if if you want to call it a
recession it's very mild one at the
moment
um and it's probably better
characterized as being a flat economy
well the government says that it wants
to make sure that we're not in recession
they want to boost growth with their tax
cutting plans will it work
well I think there are two impacts from
the tax cuts one is that
um if they cut taxes financed by
borrowing that puts money into people's
pockets and and they will spend it so
that's a short-term demand boost but
that brings with it the risk of
inflation when you have quite a tight
labor market at the moment
unemployment's very low vacancies are
very high so the risk is that instead of
in the short term instead of fueling
growth we end up with more inflation now
the the other argument for these
policies is is over the longer term they
will boost economic growth by
stimulating Enterprise and investment
but that is a much longer term process
that may operate over five to ten years
but it certainly doesn't operate
um over one to two years well yes and
just while you're talking with just
looking at live pictures of people
arriving for cabinets I think I saw
kitten wall towels going there into
number 10 just in the last few minutes
obviously ahead of this this big fiscal
event as the government is describing it
so how worried are you about the levels
of borrowing required for the
government's plans
well I think we have to see what the
chancellor says we know that there's
going to be a large amount of borrowing
from the energy price guarantee but as
you said that can cut both ways for the
economy it's helping ease the cost of
living pressures
but if we get an awful lot of taxing
reductions in in this fiscal event when
government borrowing is already quite
strained I think that is a worry for
state of the economy and for inflation